BRIAN SCHWARZ:
Welcome to the What's
New and What's Next for
Storage session here
at Google Cloud Next '21.
My name is Brian Schwarz.
And I'm joined by my colleague
here, Dave Nettleton.
We're leaders in the
product management
team here for
storage, and excited
to talk to you about the
entire storage portfolio
that Dave and I work on
along with our colleagues.
During the session
today we've broken it up
into a few different sections.
First, Dave's going to start
with the strategy for Google
Cloud Storage.
And then we're going to run
through the updates and what's
new on a number of parts of the
product line, Cloud Storage,
file, persistent disk.
And we'll end with some
discussions about transfer
in Backup Archive DR, as well
as include a few links to where
to find more information.
With that, I want
to turn it over
to Dave to start a discussion
about the strategy.
DAVE NETTLETON: Thanks, Brian.
And so just at a
very high level,
I thought it'd be
helpful to go through how
we think about our strategy and
the different parts of that.
So our goal is to
deliver easy to use,
performant, and highly available
storage for all workloads
with enterprise management
controls and insights.
This really guides how we
think about both the portfolio
of products that we have,
but also the individual
features within them.
And so at a high level,
three main types of storage
that we provide in the Cloud,
block, object, and file.
We'll spend a little bit
more time on each of these.
These cover both cloud native
and more traditional enterprise
use cases.
Together with those,
we have capabilities
for data transfer and
data protection, which
are very important
services that come hand
in hand often with storage.
And then as well as what we
deliver in terms of first party
products from Google,
we're very big
believers in having an open
ecosystem of partners here
to give customers a range of
choices for their workloads
as they bring them to the cloud.
Two big categories there would
be in file and data protection.
For file we partner closely
with NetApp, Dell EMC, and DDN.
And for Backup and DR,
Commvault, and Veeam
are two of the partners,
who amongst others
we work with very, very closely.
So let me dive in a
little bit on some
of the great
enhancements that we've
had in the products recently.
So starting with our object
storage product, Cloud Storage.
So one of the great
features in Cloud Storage,
our object storage
product, is the notion
of dual regional storage.
And what this does is
it lets you manage data
across two regions.
So without this
product, you need
to put a bucket in
each of two regions.
Each of those buckets would
have a different name.
You'd have to separately deal
with managing and copying data
from one bucket to the other.
If you had to deal
with a disaster
or you wanted to
redirect traffic
to read from one
bucket or the other,
you'd have to deal with
failover and fail back
of those storage buckets.
With dual regional storage,
we provide a product
that gives just a single bucket
that spans those two regions.
So resources in each
of those regions,
or indeed, in other regions,
can read data from that bucket.
And we will manage, behind the
scenes, the data placement.
And we provide a
single namespace
that you can read and write to.
So it's active, active from
a read and write perspective.
We provide strong consistency
over that metadata
of the bucket.
And then in the background,
we move the data,
replicate the data
between the two regions.
In the event of a failure
in one of the regions,
the application won't
notice it continue
to read the metadata that's
consistent across these two
regions, giving immediate
failover to any activity that's
happening in the other region.
One of the big enhancements
that we are announcing
is that we're going to allow
not just fixed name pairs, which
is what we have today.
We currently have a
pair of regions in Asia,
a pair of regions in the US,
and a pair of regions in Europe.
We're going to allow
customers to specify
the particular regions that
they want to create a custom
dual region across.
This is very powerful,
being able to pair together
a couple of regions and
provide a single bucket
that spans those two regions.
Together with that, we also
want to deliver a capability
to give stronger guarantees
around the recovery point
objective.
So we call this turbo
replication, where
we'll give an SLA of the data
that is written on one side
will be replicated to the
other side within 15 minutes.
And so we'll provide
an SLA back replication
for the data in these
dual region buckets.
Very excited about this in
helping customers better
support their business
continuity needs,
and also managing their data
across multiple regions.
As well as that feature,
some other enhancements
from Cloud Storage that
have happened recently.
So multipart uploads, this
has been a very common feature
ask from customers
who are looking
to make it easy to bring
large objects to the cloud,
and construct them in parts,
and finalize them in the clouds.
This has been a very popular
programmability feature.
And then a category, the next
three all around security.
So security is something we
take very, very seriously.
We work a lot with customers
around their security needs.
So we want to make sure that we
support the various workloads
that they have here,
through assured workloads,
through providing tags, bucket
level tags that let customers
reason about their data
through IAM policies,
and support
certifications like FINRA
with capabilities
like bucket lock
that let customers lock a
bucket for an extended duration
of time.
And then another enhancement
that we announced earlier in
this year--
it's relatively small,
but actually very powerful
is with Google Cloud Storage we
offer four classes of storage,
from hot all the
way down to archive.
And we let customers
tier between that data
for managing costs.
It doesn't actually--
all storage classes
have the same API and the
same fast access to data.
So even the archive tier is
online and instantly available.
But customers want a tier
between those storage classes
for cost purposes.
With a custom timestamp
as part of the metadata,
customers can now
use a measure of time
to help them make decisions
about when to tier data.
So it's a powerful capability.
Moving on from
our object storage
and cloud storage
over to file storage,
both from Filestore,
our first party product,
and also with partners.
So file storage
is a huge use case
for our customers,
particularly customers
coming from on premises,
where they have built
rich and sophisticated
workflows around enterprise file
offerings, whether that's
just as traditional file
shares, or as directories
where they're putting shared
executables as
part of workflows,
build pipelines, et cetera.
So customers are looking,
as they lift and shift
to the cloud, to have a
very powerful set of file
capabilities.
To date, we've had a
file store product that's
both a basic and a high scale.
And these have been
zonal products.
And we're really
pleased to announce
that we've launched
Filestore Enterprise, which
is a regional service.
So it will survive
a zone failure.
So we replicate data
across multiple zones.
So customers don't need
to worry about that.
They have a highly
available regional service,
backed with a four nines SLA.
And then we're also making
sure that this is then
well integrated with all of
the other enterprise features
that customers
expect in the cloud,
whether that's
Stackdriver for logging,
or our security features like
VPC Service Controls, VPN,
Interconnect to help customers
set up the appropriate security
perimeter around
their infrastructure,
and have that file product
to be part of that.
And we also want
to make sure this
is available through our
console, CLI, nice and easy
to use.
And then in particular
with GKE, to help
make it easy to provision
and get file resources there,
providing the CSI driver
support to simplify.
So as well as
Filestore Enterprise,
some other enhancements for file
that we've announced recently
is backups for Filestore Basic.
So Filestore Basic
is our zonal product.
And we've delivered
backups for that.
Filestore High Scale is
our high performance scale
of Filestore, which lets
customers scale to many tens
to up to 100 terabytes of scale
at much higher performance.
And then as well as what we've
been doing our first party
with Filestore,
lots of enhancements
through our partners, in
particular with NetApp
and Dell.
And we're seeing a lot
of customers having
a lot of success with
some of the workloads
that they're bringing
to the cloud with things
like SMB workloads for
Windows, or media rendering
and genomics.
And with that, I'll
hand back over to Brian
to tell you all a little
bit about persistent disk.
BRIAN SCHWARZ: Thanks, Dave.
So persistent disk is the
block storage offering here
in Google Cloud.
It's often used with
the Compute Engine VMs.
That's probably the
most common use case,
but it's also used quite a bit
with Kubernetes Engine, GKE
for container workloads.
And it's also used with Cloud
SQL for the managed database
offering.
So pretty popular offering, a
bunch of different use cases.
One of the new, great features
that we introduced recently
is a new class of performance,
extreme persistent disk.
And it's really targeted at the
highest performing workloads
in your data center,
particularly high end
databases, SAP HANA
being an absolutely
classic example of this.
In addition to
great performance,
another great feature
it has is the ability
to independently scale
capacity and performance.
So you can really tune the cost,
and performance, and capacity
to really get the best TCO
for your environment, just
in the persistent
disk volumes itself.
It also includes easy
to use snapshots,
which can be used for
like cloning use cases.
So you could refresh test and
dev environments and workflows
similar to that.
And also, you can attach
persistent disk volumes
to any size VM.
So again, it's another
capability of flexibility.
So you can really use the
Google Cloud infrastructure
to tune the capabilities
of the infrastructure
to exactly what you need.
So you don't pay for maybe
a really large VM just
because you need really
high performance storage.
So again, just try and give
you all that flexibility.
Dave mentioned security.
It kind of exists kind of
throughout our portfolio.
Another classic example is
here with persistent disk
is the ability to
have, of course,
at rest encryption and
encryption in transit,
and lots of flexibility
in terms of how
you manage the
keys, with customer
managed keys or
customer supplied keys.
And another thing we're
really excited about
is these constant investments
we make in the resiliency
of our system.
And extreme persistent disk
has a six nines durability,
which is a measure of how
durable the storage is.
It's really important
that we invest
in making these things
available and durable for you.
There's a number of
other enhancements
that we've had for
persistent disk that
expand beyond extreme PD.
And the first one
is probably a tie
off to what I just
talked about durability.
We have a nice public
blog posting we've done
and inclusion in some
more documentation
for PD about the really
leading durability
guarantees that we have
included in our services.
Another service that we
added earlier in the year
was balance PD.
It's an SSD class storage.
So it gives you good
performance, not as
good as extreme PD, but at
a much lower price point.
And it's a really good
offering for a lot of,
I'll say general purpose
workloads in the cloud.
People use them for boot disks,
for test and dev databases.
There's lots of reasons why
these things are interesting.
And it really gives you great
IOPS at a lower price point.
Also with balanced PD
is we have something
we refer to as regional
PD, which essentially
is synchronous replication
across the zones in a given
region.
This is a differentiated
capability
for Google Cloud, super powerful
and important for those of you
who basically need to
protect against zone failures
and essentially you're
getting synchronous rights
across multiple regions.
Used quite a bit with the
Cloud SQL offering today
to provide the highest
levels of availability
for some of your
important databases.
And, of course,
along the same lines,
increasingly investing
in APIs to be
able to deliver application
consistent snapshots,
which will really
speed the recovery time
if you need to re-instantiate
a database from a snapshot.
Another small part of the
block storage product line
here is our local SSD offering.
And you can think about
this as a counterpoint
to persistent disk that's really
targeted at ephemeral or cache
workloads.
So locally attached to the VM,
very high performance, very
high IOPS, very low latency.
Really targeted at
these caching workloads,
in-memory databases where
you need the absolute highest
level of performance, but you
don't need the persistence,
and durability,
and the enterprise
features that we have
in persistent disk.
So again, a nice addition
to the product line
earlier this year
was the support
for 9 terabyte local SSDs.
And again, like I mentioned
earlier, the ability
to attach these to many
sizes and shapes of VMs
so you can really, again, tune
performance with CPU, memory,
and storage performance, all
being targeted exactly what you
need for your workload.
And with that, I would like
to turn it back over to Dave
to talk about data transfer.
DAVE NETTLETON: Thanks, Brian.
Yeah, so data transfer
there's two major products
in the portfolio that we have
here, the Transfer Appliance
and the Transfer Service.
So starting out with
Transfer Appliance,
one exciting enhancement
that we've had
is to allow this to be available
to customers in what we
call a connected mode.
So to date, we've
had an appliance
that ships to a
customer's premises,
either, for example, to
move large amounts of data
from a data center that
they're migrating to the cloud.
Or increasingly we're seeing for
capture at the edge use cases,
where for AI/ML workloads
there's a lot of data capture
that might happen in the field.
And we want to gather
a lot of that data
and then bring it to the cloud.
So we've had a
Transfer Appliance
to allow customers
to capture that data
and ship it to the cloud.
Recently we just announced
that we'll actually allow this
to operate in a connected mode.
So you can actually drop
data onto the appliance,
and then over a
network connection
it would move the data to
the cloud on your behalf
via that connection.
So excited to see
some of the use cases
our customers will put this to.
As well as the Appliance, a lot
of enhancements on the Transfer
Service recently.
Several here that
I'll highlight.
First of all, the
Transfer Service API.
So giving programmability
control over transfers we think
will help customers much
better integrate this
into their various workflows.
Agent pools is a
capability we've
added to the agent that
is part of transfer
service for on premises.
So this is something
that is deployed
into a compute resource
and manages the transfer.
With agent rules, we're now
enabling those resources
to be better managed across
multiple transfer jobs,
and over a shared resource
like a network link,
so giving much more flexibility
control over transfer.
And then more sources and
sinks for their service.
We've added support
for Azure Data Lake V2.
And for the appliance we're
adding more locations,
with London being one that's
recently been announced.
And with that, I'll
hand back to Brian.
BRIAN SCHWARZ: Thanks, Dave.
For the last content
section, I want
to talk about Backup,
Archive, and DR.
And it's a really
important area to make sure
that you're protecting your data
in all the different places it
exists in Google Cloud.
One of the new
offerings that we just
announced in September
of '21 is a new offering
focused on containers,
Google Cloud GKE Backup.
And what we've
seen is an increase
in the number of customers
running stateful workloads
inside of containers, including
very traditional databases.
And as a result of
that, we've been
working on essentially a
new service offering that's
targeted at protecting the
data inside these stateful
containers.
It has a nice
orchestration built into it
that essentially allows you
to take regular PD snapshots
to protect the data inside
these stateful containers.
And it gives you pretty
flexible recovery options
to recover individual
containers,
as well as full clusters, both
in the normal region where
it was running, as well as
potentially for a DR use case
to reinstantiate it
inside of another region.
There is flexibility
to basically manage
your backup policy, scheduling,
recurring snapshots,
as well as setting the
retention cycles on how long
you want to keep these
snapshots around.
And as GKE and
containers continues
to be used for more
important, very traditional,
enterprise class workloads,
it's important to have offerings
like this that
essentially help you
meet compliance requirements.
So you can create
backups for the data
for inside of these containers.
And we also have the
ability to do pre and post
hooks so you can
also get application
consistent snapshots.
Across the rest of our
Backup and Archive portfolio,
there's a number of other
things that have been going on.
In particular, last
year at the end of 2020
we acquired Actifio.
And it's the real centerpiece
of our first party backup
investments going forward.
Actifio was a
Google Cloud partner
and had an offering called
Actifio Go in the marketplace.
And we've been working
on making that offering
more native inside
of Google Cloud,
to really simplify the
deployment of this service,
integrated billing.
And, of course, it leverages
all the great technology
Actifio had as it
came into Google
around incremental
forevers in terms
of speeding up the backups
after the first one.
It's really targeted,
again, at these mission
critical databases, SAP HANA,
Oracle, MySQL, et cetera.
And it's really important for us
to continue to invest in this,
particularly about making it
a first class service that'll
be more natively
integrated into some
of the higher level managed
services as we go on.
And to round out this, I
wanted to briefly mention
some of the partners, just
like Dave did for file.
There's a number of
data protection partners
we work with, two of
them who have done
some recent enhancements
to the offerings
to support Google Cloud
are Veeam and Commvault.
So Veeam V11, which
is often used on prem,
now supports Google Cloud
Storage as a backup target.
So you can really think about
the tape replacement use case.
I like to tell people, one
of the hidden gems of GCS
is some of the cheaper
tiers of storage
have very low latency
in terms of access.
So you can really use these
cheaper tiers to protect
your data and have compliance.
But if you ever
need to get it back,
you don't need to wait hours
or days to do restores.
And also, there is a new Veeam
for Backup for Google, V2
that just got released
on the marketplace.
And it also supports the
archive class tiering,
which, again, will reduce the
cost for long term retention.
And lastly, Commvault
has done a great job.
They're a member
of our marketplace,
recently came onto
the marketplace.
And has some great capabilities.
Obviously well known
for VMware backups,
and have done some nice
integration with Google Cloud
VMware Engine.
So again, an exciting
new partnership.
We're excited to work with these
partners as well as others,
again, to provide a wide array
of backup, archive, and DR
solutions, both from Google
and from our partner ecosystem.
So to round out
the session, I just
wanted to talk a
little bit about where
to learn more information.
And there's a couple
of other sessions
here at Google Cloud
Next that I think
if you're interested
in this section would
be useful to look at.
There's a more specific session
that goes a little bit deeper
into Filestore Enterprise, which
is something Dave mentioned.
There's a wider HA and
availability section
that talks about a number
of the capabilities,
as well as some
customer sessions
sprinkled in throughout.
So I really hope you
get value out of these.
Included a number
of links to where
to find best practices
and additional technical
documentation, as well
as some of the training
and certification links on how
to get more training and get
certified.
And one of the things
that I was excited to see
is that last year the Google
Cloud Professional Cloud
Architect was the highest
paying certification.
So great kind of career
option for people
to invest in themselves.
And we're excited.
Hopefully this session
was a good overview
of all the things that is what's
new with Google Cloud Storage.
Enjoy the rest of the event.
And we'll see you again soon.
Thank you.